okay what do we got today I got no pink
cards
gu
okay
so was is this oh this is my bill right
this is the first one you sit there all
morning no I not going to do that I'm
not going to do that okay so I'm going
to have distributed right now an
amendment
um but so Aiden Aiden are you going to
bills okay all right come on come on up
yeah okay so as I mentioned yesterday
that um the department over uh
Department come to me and they want me
to put in bills which I would have to
say uh in this case I pretty much know
what's going on with each of the liquor
bills whereas some of those banking
insurance I'm a little little foggy on
but uh but it's uh um important is that
uh that yes we're we're uh dealing all
these different issues um and I will say
that uh you now have an amendment that
we just distributed and uh the story
behind this amendment mment is that um
this is an issue that came to my
attention right after we had to put in
bills and we we the bill 1018 had a lot
had a lot of stuff already in it and so
at that point we just decide that we'll
wait till now to actually introduce this
amendment but all of these all these
things you're going to hear today from
the commission with my name this is the
commission wants these bills so it's
it's not um and it's not like their like
this one Amendment which is technically
coming separately but it is something
that they these are all issues that
we're trying to deal with so good
morning
gentlemen and morning sir so all they
can say is said whoever speaks you needs
to keep the microphone right in your
mouth and uh and the best thing to do is
go through the bill by section certainly
and just you know like section one
section two and just so everybody
understands what's in the bill okay
thank you
first of all thank you uh chairman hunt
and committee members for the record uh
my name is Matthew Culver I'm a
lieutenant with the New Hampshire State
Liquor Commission division of
enforcement and Licensing over the
course of the past few legislative
sessions uh we've asked for um some
changes on uh certain statutes to
provide Clarity for our industry members
and and Clarity for uh interpretation by
the division
um this bill is a uh technical bill that
provides some of those clarities I'll go
by uh through each of them paragraph by
paragraph So in number one paragraph
number one uh pertaining to the
combination license in RSA
17818 it strikes out the words not
holding on premises licenses the full
sentence there is off premises licenses
shall be issued only for groceries and
drug stores not holding on premise Li
licenses the reason for this change is
title 13 currently has a license type
combination conditional license that
combines one or more license types the
most frequent license types utilized
within this license is the combination
license which is an off- premise license
and a restaurant license an on-premise
license the recommended change
eliminates the contradictory wording in
RSA
17818 okay everybody follow that one
good paragraph number two is a change in
the definitions um striking out off sale
and uh inserting off
premises the second is striking out on
sale and inserting on premises so this
would have been something that was in
the statute a long long time ago and we
just never got around to correct and the
1990 recodification probably Aiden
passed that you know when he was y when
he was Chief perfect now paragraph
number three on premises cocktail lounge
licenses um is striking out the word
unaccessible and inserting inaccessible
for a grammatic
change did you did you use uh the the
computer to come up with that
replacement after it was brought to my
attention several times yes I did Google
it and artificial intelligence help you
out with that one exactly um number five
is the same striking out unaccessible
inserting
inaccessible what number four was
Club okay got rid of
the got rid of the word Club oh I'm
sorry yes um striking out the word uh
club for the rental
facilities okay if you guys really want
to have entertainment you want to look
up how many different kinds of liquor
licenses we have and uh and clubs Club
did become confusing because we had
different kinds of clubs so 54 to be
exact 54 54 so if you would say is well
why can't we simplify that why can't we
make them different well because each
one each one that came in had a special
circumstance so either you create a
separate license for it or you put them
in the general license and say they're
eligible because of so you you don't
save any words in the statute by doing
it separately and it's a little easier
for us to actually have their own
license number or license description
correct all right paragraph number five
just to reiterate was striking out
unaccessible inserting inaccessible and
paragraph number six is striking out
distilling and inserting license to
distill uh twice in the same
paragraph and the reasoning behind this
is through a recent legislative change
in 2022 the licensing fees for the
liquor manufacturer license was tiered
and the in the change uh in the liquor
manufacturing statute who distilled a
th000 cases or more per year would pay
an annual license fee of692 and a liquor
manufacturer distill less than th000
cases per year would pay an annual fee
of 300 the proposed change provides
consisten were those fees again 1692 and
300 and 300 right 300 that was right for
the low cheap the cheap one okay the
proposed change provides consistency
with the intended provisions of RSA 1786
and RSA 17829 the fees
okay
great and I I assume you want to have
enforcement talk about this amendment
Mark do you want to talk about this this
hookah liing we're putting it that's the
reason why we put we're putting it in
this bill
absolutely thank you so Matt were you
were prepared to talk about this a
little bit I was yes oh okay I'm
sorry go ahead Matt so the amendment uh
that is before each of you now um it is
relative and many of you may remember um
two legislative sessions ago we
discussed the cigar bar this is
inserting the hookah lounge uh or hookah
um criteria to be included in the um
cigar bar and Cigar Bar related
items into that definition so what this
will do will allow the businesses that
primarily operate as a hookah lounge to
be able to be in compliance with the
cigar bar
license okay so they still have all the
same requirements in terms of sales of
non alcohol not alcohol but related to
60% of the quarterly gross revenue will
be in cigar or cigar related products
hookah is now incl included in the cigar
related
products and and the reality is they
have been operating anyways but this
clarifies it and sets the ground rules
that's correct chairman yes uh and and
we got a away Way by not creating a new
license because we're just no new
license we're just exping a current
license
correct okay any questions from the
committee members yes representative
buros could you let us know what do you
smoke in a hookah because I don't know
thank you for that question and it's
shisha tobacco shisha tobacco what is
shisha tobacco uh it's a it's a region
isn't
it yeah it's it's U commonly uh utilized
by the middle eastern culture uh but
it's a sticky form of tobacco that's
smoked in the hookah
pipe you get high on
no what it's made sticky with you better
not be I I don't believe that you can I
I believe there is some sort of um you
know equivalent to uh nicotine in it
some sort of
stimulant okay representative
a thank you Mr chair um thank you for
your testimony how does this uh
Amendment affect existing hookah bars uh
what additional uh burdens does it place
on them if
any thank you for the question
um we don't have a license type for
hookah bars so the the hookah the
establishments that primarily um operate
as a hookah lounge fall under the cigar
bar license and that has been the issue
those license uh types or those business
models have had a difficult time
maintaining this 60% quarterly gross
revenue in cigar related products
because most of what they sell is hookah
so this change includes the hookah into
the cigar related products making it
much easier for them to be in compliance
with the statute yeah and as the sponsor
I could say they requested this this so
so we do have a card for them to speak
to it yeah for the question and
representative uh the hookah the the
selling of hookah actually worked
against
um the percentage so these
establishments were were getting audited
not frequently but frequent enough that
it actually works to the positive not
the
negative just followup question yep so
does this incentivize hookah bars to
also sell cigars and other tobacco
products they can sell other um tobacco
products and uh yeah cigar related items
they have been already all along
correct meet the requirement right it's
the cigar related products that go
towards the
60% um and as the chief said that is
absolutely correct anything else they
sell whether it's a t-shirt or uh uh a
soda that goes against their 60%
requirement
right okay yep representating M you any
any thought on the contents of the
shisha pellets right so they're they're
basically pucks like that are compressed
like you said a bit sticky and flavored
with all sorts of flavors correct and
one of them is about a pack of
cigarettes roughly if you smoke the
whole thing yourself which is uncommon
but it can you can put whatever you want
in there so is there any any thought to
discussing in here other additives that
may or may not be more or less
harmful we have and thank you for the
question uh we have not seen that in our
hookah lounges uh currently um any other
product being utilized in those um so
that
that is not something that um we are
now okay representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair just out of
curiosity
but what is the point of not allowing
bar I think it goes back to the indoor
smoking act um and prohibiting the the
cigarette smoking um that is an item
that was discussed in this committee a
couple sessions ago uh but uh that's
what it is pertaining to directly
correct that is the
history okay so yes Chief did you say
you wanted offer up something else I all
I wanted to do is uh just add keep the
mic close your I know everybody wants to
say Thank you Mr chairman uh
representative um what we're looking at
is hookah for what it is and if it's an
adulterated product that isn't uh in its
in its purest form what it is then then
we will be looking at that as a
violation but thank you for your
question it's a great
question
yes represent
bam how many hookah lounges are there in
the state I know that there was you know
maybe two or three in uh in Manchester
but they're not there anymore so I'm not
are somewhere around 17 I think yeah I
there's 15 and
two
dozen thank you for the question it's 17
oh yeah Cigar Bar
licenses oh 17 cigar bars because we
don't know which ones are actually
they're not distinguished as hookah
because we've never we cre we know that
five predominantly five are hookas are
predominantly um so 17 cigar bars and we
know five are are hookah hooker
oriented okay good okay
thank you very
much and chair will call Moren Weston
who is
representing can't believe they call
themselves air sorry Mr
chairman air or clouding the air maybe
for good morning Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Mora Weston and I
am here this morning on behalf of
advanced inhalation
rituals get that let me get it ad
advance inhalation in rituals ritual
okay very and I have with me written
testimony from the NASA National hookah
Community Association so I will leave
that with you um we are here in support
of the amendment and we encourage you to
pass or recommend uh 18 1018 as a Ed um
we think that this is a good opportunity
to Simply clarify the law uh the hookah
lounges have been operating in a bit of
a gray area as you've heard and
clarifying that 60% of their quarterly
Revenue shall come from the sale of
hookah or cigars will give them a
regulatory construct with which they can
comply um I should also mention that in
the amendment there is a provision that
the hookah lounge would comply with what
I'll refer to as last call imposed on
any uh business is selling liquor so
that is new and hasn't been in law to
date um in general this will give
everybody I think more regulatory uh
certainty if not certainty
predictability and um with that I'm
happy to take any questions and
consideration represent Bros this is
just a curiosity question how
carcinogenic are the um inhaling the
Hookah Smoke do you know the total
product is as I understand it 15%
tobacco and I don't know how that
translates to how cars is but it is FDA
sure okay great thank you for your time
and
consideration anybody else would like to
uh speak on House Bill
10:18 seeing none close the public
hearing on
1018 oh so I I gotta have a system Chris
I'm getting the blue
more is there a typo in that in that
bill or this some I was going to ask the
question on line line 30 or do I just
means uh what what are you looking at
just so Matt Matt
knows where where do you see this in the
amendment
okay in the amendment and what where
what line line
30 oh no Z of exposure yeah do where did
that Z come
from Martin do you know where the Z came
0110 no ounce of exposure no z z of
exposure but not limit to an increased
risk of cancer and heart disease and
that no Z of exposure to second no
yeah so what what's what's why is the Z
computer filling filling in the blank I
believe that there's a typo that I might
not have caught when I reviewed the
language okay um the last sentence of
Roman 4 is and that no level of exposure
to secondhand exposure so that must be
the Greek word for
level Greek
letter
level okay great all right thank you
thank
you
sir all set
yep thank you Mr chairman uh the intent
of uh Bill
1076 is to allow the wine manufacturer
to uh hold their uh one on premises
license either on the premises of the
manufacturing facility
or on the premises of their wine uh
outlet the intent on this bill is
because there are circumstances with the
wine manufacturers that have their
location on premises that may not be
suitable to have a restaurant there so
this would expand if they're allowed to
have one on premise license if they're
allowed to have a wine manufacturer
retail outlet they could either have
their one on premise at their
manufacturing facility or at their
retail
outlet and this was request by there was
some by an industry member yes yeah
there was an industry one manufacturer
that wanted to correct have have this so
just to jog people's memory um several
years ago we passed allow a uh beverage
Manu manufacturer and wine manufacturer
to have a separate
facility um and uh I guess the not sure
we mentioned names or not but there's a
certain wine manufacturer that's right
on 101 and that uh
had and um and but but that is an on-
premise leny anyways that location she
hers but she did have they they did have
another location at a mall to sell their
wine uh but in this case it's now its
reversed the person uh doesn't want to
have that arm premise license at their
actual location they want to do it at
their so-called retail location
theoretically the retail location is
more located for retail activity and
therefore U more apt to have a
successful on premise
restaurant yes representative pusi thank
you chairman H uh question this says or
does this allow the manufacturer to have
one on premise and one at the retail
location thank you for the question
representative they are allowed one on
premises license so that
license could be on the premises of
their manufacturing facility or the
premises of their uh retail there but
they're only getting one they only can
have one per statute further further
question inquire thank you U Mr chair
would would this prohibit a manufacture
from having a second license say if they
have a a manufacturing facility in the
answer is yes it would Pro it would
prohibit it thank you
so so and I guess the other thing I I
want to just talk everybody's memory
where this all comes back to was the
concept that we were a three tier State
and that meant that if you were a
manufacturer you would not be a
retailer okay and yes we we have chipped
away at that three tier statute uh and
the most famous obviously was brew pubs
uh but this is just a little bit to
allow the manufacturers then we allow
manufacturers to be able to sell at
their location and then this is the next
step is which is to allow them to have
an on- premise license which
theoretically if we were True Believers
of the three tier we would never have
allowed that in the first
place represent B yes uh thank you for
taking my question in the case of leel
Winery they're in uh Bedford and I think
that's where they produce their wines
and they so this bill doesn't affect
them it doesn't because they are they're
are there it's there on premise right
but they also have several other
facilities where they do they own a
facility where they sell their wines
correct so well one they can only have
one I don't they have a few one license
more than one place yeah oh okay so
how does that happen so if a leny were
to have multiple uh wine manufacturing
facilities they can already retail sell
at their wine manufacturer facility
without utilizing their wine
manufacturer retail app
out right because she has more than one
wine rate licensed as a wine
manufacturer
yes okay have we confused you all
yet uh thank you Mr chairman I'm I'm
guessing that the reason for just one
license is to limit the the how much
their production is is that
correct no it's just because we had this
we had we've always said that we were a
three tier State and so we were we were
reluctantly allowing them to have this
other retail location and mainly because
if if theoretically uh I would say not
so much for wine but certainly for uh a
beverage manufacturer the facility might
be located in an industrial Zone and
really not appropriate for a retail like
location and so the rationale was that
yes if they want to have a retail
location that's in a mall you know down
stre um
at that time we we were telling them no
they had to make beer in the mall and
that seemed a little uh awkward and
cumbersome and probably inappropriate
and that's when we decide to allow them
you oh representative Gibbs I'm sorry
thank you Mr chair uh just to be sure I
understand um you would allow uh the
manufacturer to sell for on premises
consumption only in one
place that is either in the
manufacturing facility or in a retail
location
or just one place no matter how many
locations they might actually
own thank you for the question
representative and that is correct yes
they're only allowed by Statute one on
premises license thank you right but to
make sure we everybody understands they
can sell you know samples and sell and
do in both locations but the key element
the on premise location has that whole
other extend which is food and it's a
restaurant license it's a restaurant
license remember when you're an on
premise you're a restaurant off premise
store um thank you for taking this
followup I still don't understand how
leel can have several onsite restaurants
cities for her for the situation with
leel specifically I would have to review
her licensing file to see how that
structure is set up but um generally
speaking per manufacturing license
you're allowed the one on premises
license so her those facili would have
to be independently licensed as
manufacturers yeah so okay I know the
one on amher is where's the other one
tusin Village tusin village dery tusin
Village and dairy now do they have
Vineyards there yes okay so basically
they have two different manufacturing
sites so that doubles the lenser PO
possibilities for them do they distill
so that no no they're Winery I mean not
distill but do they wi they make wine
make wine and dairy yes they do okay
yeah and I know I know I've seen the
wine making they do in ammer so that
that means they're making wine in both
locations that means they could
theoretically have well four
locations no you're right because excuse
me she has a Vineyard in Dairy but I
don't think she actually makes wine I
think it goes back to ammer I think she
takes it right no cuz there's no in that
fac
I know that building it's right it's
four miles from my house well maybe we
just need to have a road trip to go
visit
facilities yeah and I I don't even think
exactly I
okay let's not pick on one of our Port
New Hampshire
manufacturers who we want to be
supportive
of okay so do you have a question
representing W
yes she has a like a little store this
would you believe okay would you believe
that a certain Winery four miles from my
house has a little store there
so does she need a
license does she need two licenses or is
she not allowed to get any Beverage Wine
anybody you know any manufacturer is
allowed to sell their product at the
location and that goes back to flag Hill
was the first one where he was making uh
John Stark vodka and how embarrassing
was that this is probably when you were
back you on the committee when back then
that when when that that he said you
know kind of ridiculous people come in
and do a tasting but I can't sell it to
them I got to send them to a liquor
store to buy it and that's how we
trampled on the three tier system way
back when some of us did make a field
trip to flag Hill just personally
inspected well this was good this is a
good get everybody understanding the the
nuances of our and as you can see it's
the consequence of each action you make
has has a you know uh trickle down
effect you know a domino effect that how
we affect it but all of it is is and I I
look at Scott when I say this that all
of this is the the trampling on the
three tier tier concept yes so and there
will be more of that later we still
cutting some more
here okay how are we doing and anybody
sign in on the blue sheet okay waved off
on that all right we'll close the public
so um Aiden and and Matt can you guys
just fill out a card just so we can have
in the files when if somebody were able
people
[Music]
build
sticking in the each bill so that so
that right well for because you were
testifying on these bills so
theoretically if someone would open the
folder they say who were these people so
if you both fill out a card right but
you actually you could I think you could
put both your names on one card that is
true we we have seen that happen okay
good morning again good morning chairman
and thank you uh House Bill
1358 uh it it in
concept is a bill that combines uh the
contract manufacturing and tenant
manufacturing that is currently set up
in the beverage side of the house for
the wine manufacturers and liquor
manufacturers so it's taking the
concepts of the
tenant uh Brewing changing that to
tenant
manufacturing as well as the
contract Brewing changing that to
contract manufacturing for all of the
manufacturing licenses the liquor
manufacturers the wine manufacturers
and the beverage manufacturers making
all of those
consistent um there is an immense amount
of
complexity um in this bill with all of
the name changes we have been in touch
with our industry partners and the New
Hampshire beverage
Association uh who this week has
provided us with some
information um about some
recommendations to the language in this
uh certainly this bill were to go to
subcommittee uh we would be in touch
with them and devise some or tighten up
any uh holes in the language that exists
now yes so I want don't to describe what
the purpose what's the problem we're
trying to solve here what is say so with
contract
Brewing
is most simply explained by I have a
recipe in and I'm bringing it to your
manufacturing facility for you to make
that recipe tenant Brewing otherwise
known as an alternating proprietorship
or alt prop in the federal system is
that I don't have a facility so I'm
leasing your facility to make my own
product I'm using your own your
equipment to make my product now this
has been attractive because of the the M
uh um startup cost of some of these
breweries or wine manufacturing liquor
manufacturing facilities they can share
the equipment in some instances at least
one with on the brewery side we've had
uh a ly not necessarily share equipment
but they share space they have their own
equipment but they share one General
location this concept of the contract
and tenant has never been applied to the
liquor or wine manufacturers the intent
of this bill is to allow the same thing
for the liquor manufacturers and the
wine manufacturers as we do for the
Brewers again it's complex and uh
bill this is the one that Brian Ferguson
called me on is that uh I believe Mr
Ferguson had some issu concerns concerns
so yes he called me as well well I well
I sent him to i s them on you well thank
you and I have not had the opportunity
to speak to oh to see what we have make
sure address okay so this might this
theoretically is going to get amended
then when we get to sub commit I believe
it is going to yes chman okay yeah okay
so I can you you guys know how I like to
tell a story so my f most famous story
is that uh many many many many moths
ago when um Mr kooch from uh who had had
this his grandfather's recipe to make an
ale and wanted to start Sam Adams ale um
he had no facility as a matter of fact
he was never in the beverage business to
begin with and so he needed someone to
contract Brew now here I am in going to
college in Boston University and lone
behle I I'm looking at my very first
bottle of Sam Adams and what does it say
on it brewed in Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania and what happened well he
his initial contract and I I've read his
book cuz he I got an autograph coffee of
his book uh but uh in he does talk about
how um he to he went shopping for a
tenant Brewer to make the original Sam
Adams so it Sam Adams is actually Iron
City Light Iron City beer but uh in
using that
facility okay any question
questions Mr chairman I I I know that
the New Hampshire Brewers Association
sent an email this morning with
testimony I'm not sure that that was
received or not but um that's included
in here as well okay all right any
questions committee
members as you can see all of this is
enabling legislation to allow to uh to
do expand what these these companies
these uh manufacturers and we have so
many different kinds of manufacturers so
is it gets complicated as we move along
here
okay and last but not least we have Brew
brew
PBS
okay
minutes ahead of
our
yourselves
so
so why restrict the hours in the hooker
lodes I can tell you that I've been
driving around 3:00 in the morning to
Manchester and that
packed that
pack where where's Lo loue on Valley you
know the the martial arts
places
they
I
okay so as I said before the original
tramping on the three- tier system was
the
brub and now they're not
done so why don't you explain this one
to
everybody thank you again chairman and
committee
members um
H Bill
1380 uh affects the Brew Pub license and
uh RSA 178 colon 13 by inserting a new
paragraph in that
license uh which reads nothing in this
section shall prevent a holder of a brew
puup license from holding an on premises
or off- premises license under this
chapter provided that a the pro pu
license does not hold any other type of
manufacturing license under this title
and B an on- premises or off- premise
premises licy holding two or more Brew
Pub licenses shall not sell more than
5,000 barrels of beer or cider to any
retailer
this um language uh was a a collective
um work group between the New Hampshire
Brewers Association the Restaurant
loding Association and um the division
of enforcement to um
expand upon the Privileges of of the
Brew Pub license what the issue has been
in a uh I'm sure the New Hampshire
restaurant Lodging Association is is
here and they will uh testify to this
but um one of their constituents uh has
um had
a uh several restaurant licenses
throughout the
state um and the idea behind this is to
have the ability for a brew pub license
which by Statute is considered a
manufacturing
license um integrated with the on
premise restaurant licenses now as uh
chairman hunt has
explained um there's a a couple concerns
in this with RSA 17911 and the
prohibited interest and that is the
whole three tier system but in of in it
of itself The Brew public license you
have to have a restaurant license in
order to have a brew pub license it's
integrated within that license type so
you're a you're considered a
manufacturer and you're considered a
restaurant you're no more of a
manufacturer than you are a
restaurant and that is what
representative Hunt is is referring to
in the three- tier system you're taking
two of the tiers and combining them
together
now for the purposes of
um the issue at hand here what was
happening in the industry is
that lenes who had multiple on premise
licenses could not get a brew pub
license because it would be considered
crossing the tier um in a violation of
17911 this expands that by
allowing those lenses the on premise
restaurant licenses to have this type of
license only not a beverage
license uh
but what what's our self-distribute law
I know I passed that many years ago what
so in the beverage manufacturer or the
Brew yeah right exactly so but I'm
saying they're going to be delivering to
their own locations or or do they have
to use a
distributor that that is the part B in
this in in this uh section and and this
is sell more mean it was about self-
Distributing right so under the beverage
manufacturing law
17812 if you produce under 15,000
barrels you are allowed to
self-distribute up to 5,000 barrels so
this is consistent with that portion of
the beverage manufa ufacturing law under
the current law in the Brew Pub you only
can produce 2500 barrels and you can
self-distribute all 2500 of those
barrels so what part B is saying here is
if you have four restaurant licenses you
can now get a brew pub
license if you get another Brew Pub
license then you can self-distribute an
extra 2500 barrels for a total of 5,000
barrels which is the same as the
beverage manufacturers can can self-
distribute and you're limited to that if
you got another Brew Pub license you
couldn't you're not going to be able to
distribute 7500 barrels and I will tell
you that we have 31 brew pubs right now
amazing in in the uh in our licensing uh
structure and I believe it's only two of
them that are even remotely close to the
2500 barrels
so nobody's even well the whole concept
of the of the brw was that you're really
only manufacturing enough for your for
your own sales for your that thank you
chairman that's 100% correct the entire
intent of this law that was the right
and I will assure you all I was not
around when Brew Pub pet law passed you
can't blame me for that
one nor was
I were you
wrong so and were you enforcement were
you Chief at the time uh no I wasn't
Chief chairman I was an investigator but
first Brew Pub showed up in Portsmouth
uh right ports right and uh it it was
requested by a gentleman named Peter
Egleston who has gone on to open a
number of other Brewery facilities in
New Hampshire um and his argument was I
make beer in my other in other states
where I have a license particularly
Massachusetts I would like to be able to
to serve the beer that I make to the
people who come to my
restaurant and the legislature in its
infinite wisdom has always decided to
work and help the businessman who's
trying to expand his presence in New
Hampshire and and uh the legislature I
believe was probably regulated revenues
passed it was regulated revenues yeah
passed I I can't hear you I cannot hear
you I'm sorry uh P yeah PMI Brewery the
first but it's yeah it's pman Brewery
what what was the other because his wife
was name on one of them and his name was
um I mean I think what what what he did
was try to make take that first step
into modernization of uh I'm not sure
people foresaw the tier implications as
clearly as they do today I'd be shocked
at Clark Corson didn't do anything at
that time I'm shocked he would not have
tried to say something about it
but I don't know if there's any other
questions about that process all right
represent M thank you Mr chairman it's
Tim MCU from marac um this makes me
think of our local folks AEL eaner
because they they produce and
self-distribute and it was one of the
first places that I knew that ran their
own refrigerator trucks all around the
state delivering their beer produced in
marac to the restaurants
so your first explanation was about as
clear as a Guinness to me so I'm getting
there um help me understand how this
affects the little guy like that can
this just lets them produce more F 5,000
or what are they what are they likely to
be licensed as now and I don't I don't
believe they serve food I think it's all
in thank you representative I I'm not
sure how that specific license is
licensed whether they're a beverage
manufacturer nano brewery or their
license as a brew pub I would have to
check
that well he has a pub and he has all
kinds of events there and music and
whatever and then he has a food truck in
the his his claim to fame was for this
committee was that was getting to after
covid that to continue to allow him to
be reselling directly to the
consumer yeah he does both yeah that was
that was we passed that legislation
because of
him so I just want I'm familiar I just
want to know how this affects them
because I don't entirely counts on what
his underlying license is sorry it
counts on what his underlying license is
which I don't know manufacturer or is he
a brew pub I would think he's a
manufacturer I don't believe he was a
brew pub but so can you be a
manufacturer and and have uh you know a
bar and a lounge and entertainment and
you know that's what the other girl were
talking about the having an on- premise
license so he must have both be a
manufacturer and have an on premise
license so he must have both then
because he self-d distributes and he has
occasional transient entertainment and a
food truck and whatnot food truck's not
connected no he doesn't have a food
truck he delivers he he puts in the back
of a truck and delivers to your house
yes he has an actual food truck that
serves the food what I'm saying is they
don't serve the food they bring food
trucks to serve alcohol no they don't
serve alcohol food a food truck
but thank you for the question because I
I I think you know the complexity of
this is is noted on this um I I think
another important aspect to bring up
with this is what has been done as
for this to be allowed to happen right
so if I own four restaurants and I want
to open up a brew pub license what has
been occurring now in is completely uh
uh um Allowed by Statute is to turn
those four restaurants into brew pubs so
TTP approval is granted for a home brew
kit that is placed on the table and now
they're considered brw pups and licensed
as Brew pups and that is simply not the
correct way to fix this
issue um so this this is the correct way
to fix the issue um and um
I think that the industry Partners will
be able to um come to an agreement on on
done thank you Mr chairman you you
mentioned the word complicated um
convoluted seems even more more
appropriate what why is all this
necessary I I don't I I guess maybe I
don't fully understand the three-tier
system and why we need it but it just
seems to
be quite frankly ridiculous that uh all
of a sudden you're limited to 5,000 or
it just doesn't make sense to me too
many rules okay so I'll I'll take this
you um and and you
know the only only reason we actually
have liquor now in Commerce was that cuz
I had um look now
the you know the uh Castle on the clouds
had a spring water and Jim deur you know
came in legislation to allow them to
self-distribute Spring Water beer they
were making a beer probably the only
person who still has a luck now t-shirt
but the beer and because it really was
the very first beer that was you made
here in New Hampshire you know as as a
as a small batch brewing and um needs to
say that I had to negotiate with the
beer distributors and we came up with a
compromise and and Donna citech was so
impressed he said okay you guys can have
the liquor you can have all the liquor
bills and so the struggle is that you
you have this concept of the three tier
that you were going to that it was
literally was something that came out of
the end of the pro bition and which was
that we're going to uh ensure that we
won't have this speak easys back of that
that was going on you know when ille
when all the illegal beer was being sold
and uh then then I say this a a trivia
question what state ignored the
prohibition and I I I looked at the list
and I said the only one I can think is
possibly would be Maine and that was the
answer then Maine actually ignored the
provision that main had nothing to do
with the provision so so evidently you
could you know well they're right next
to Canada so all the all the Canadian
boes probably coming in there so anyway
the three tier for whatever it's worth
is a model that we've had a long time
and and Scott at one time made a
presentation to the to the committee
about you know the defense of the three-
tier system so having said that every
time we have these new Industries New
Hampshire you know trying to come in and
we are a mother mayi right so everything
is illegal until we make it legal and so
each time we struggle with how do
we how do we take care of this problem
how do we you know give this business
this opportunity without totally
throwing the three tier or whatever in
the trash can and the problem I would
say when you have this mother mayi
system is that every time you do pass
something like a brew every time you do
this now you created uh a whole industry
invested in perpetuating that
exemption and so you know the example I
give people is that if you go I went to
Montana and I wanted to get a a
margarita at a at a restaurant and they
said well we don't have that license we
only in Montana they limit to how many
liquor licenses they have per town okay
and why haven't they fix that problem
because everyone who had to pay that
250,000 or whatever to buy that license
to open the restaurant well make damn
sure they don't want that law to be
repealed and so we have that same
problem that each one of these things
and this is a classic case that we have
to restaurant lodging is is involved in
negotiation the Distributors are
involved in negoti everybody is going to
you know because we're somewhat fussing
around with three tier here and and so
each one has to say okay are we willing
to live with this little chipping away
of the law and so yes and and and and
you take in totality it looks like we
have this crazy bizarre
Byzantine you know system but it's I
guess and all I can say is that I'm I've
been doing this long enough that I I can
fortunately tell you the story and why
each one happened and what was the the
negotiate what was the process how we
got there and that's what you call
institutional knowledge and I hope
someday I can impart on all of you so
you all can have the same institutional
knowledge
thank you Mr chairman I fully understand
it now I appreciate
it representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair um as a
latecomer to this whole system uh may I
ask you a couple of questions just to be
sure I understand sure thank you uh okay
the three- tier system do I understand
correctly tier one is manufacturing
corre tier two is retail sales no tier
two is distribution wholesale industry
other words the
manufacturer you the whole idea that
that that the original tide house that
which is what we were trying to get rid
of was that um anheiser Bush would make
the beer they'd stick it on their their
truck and their on have their
horses clop down the street and they
would take it to a establishment that
they
owned okay and then so we did want
ownership of all three tiers that we
wanted separate ownership that the whole
idea was you could if you own one you
can't own any of the other two and then
tier three is both retail sales and bars
and restaurants correct and that's what
we call on premise and off-
premise okay so tier two has essentially
part A off premise and Part B on premise
tier
two is is just distributed tier three is
yes both on and all the all these
licenses we're talking about in terms of
can you who sells it is the tier three
okay I have I have another question this
is both broader and maybe a very stupid
question I don't know but why don't we
let the free market operate let Commerce
operate and then if we see a problem
make it illegal rather than making
everything illegal until we come up with
this bantine system very good question
and that goes back to and I it turns my
tell in the story that goes back to the
end of the prob
bition so when the when the prob bition
ended what they ended up doing they
really actually allowed any state to be
continued to be a dry State somebody any
state could have said no we're not going
to do anything but they said when inste
was okay now now instead of being
everything's legal and then and then you
just make uh make things illegal based
what you don't like which is what you
were saying in the free market
it was absolutely the complete opposite
everything is illegal until the state
decides that it's legal and that's why I
say this is mother mayi and I thought
this was the only mother mayi
legislation that occurs until I got into
a zoning issue and learning that zoning
is also the same situation so if you
want to make a correlation in your mind
about what we do here it's the same
thing as zoning and that is you can't do
something in a Zone unless it's
specifically stated that I was
allowed thank you representative grassy
welcome to Commerce well thank you uh Mr
chairman I and I guess all our questions
are aimed at you now so in instead of
the speaker I was the sponsor he can
leave so but uh yeah I I certainly
understand the three-tier system the
thing I concern that I have is that you
know as we know I mean UNH actually has
a program in craft brewing now and the
thing is is is as has gone on in the
Northwest is happening here in the
Northeast and that craft brew Brewing is
becoming a really big thing correct and
I don't know if there's if there's
something more we need to do but I hate
to see us
restrict craft brewing and brew pubs uh
the way we seem to be doing it here um I
don't know I know we have some very
powerful Distributors here in the State
uh so they're that number two in that
tier but we need to encourage more this
craft brewing in the state of New
Hampshire because it's becoming very
lucrative and as we all know from
yesterday's testimony we have some of
the highest alcohol consumption in the
nation so uh but uh and having gone to
UNH I know that a l beer our beer tax
has been flat it's been literally flat
and that is that even all these
Sparkling Waters and all these other
products you know come in the market
they they and and and terms of even the
custom Brewers will tell you that they
have to keep coming out with new
products because if you you they're like
their original products like you know
they people they get bored of it they
don't want to they want all these new
varieties I would say is that yes over
the history of this committee and
certainly while on my watch we have done
amazing things to facilitate that for
instance we created a nano license okay
we which was allowed them to be small we
allow them to have tastings we allow
them to charge for those tastings we've
done so over the years we have done
amazing amount of things for the cust
Brewer I would say the number one block
difficulty is and this is when you go
back to the Distributors is for a
distributor to make money on a on a any
product youve got there's got they got
to sell enough volume of it okay and
there was is a problem when you have so
many guys in this business it's hard to
to make to sell a volume now the other
issue we're going to get and I believe
we had the bill is is
Growlers right and it's not just beer
but it's also cider that we're seeing
come up I'm intimately cider because I
have a son-in-law who has a North North
Country cider yes is my
son-in-law is part of that so yes I'm
intimately aware of that and I told him
right from the get-go that they were
never going to be able to compete
against beer because they don't water
the product down we went to we went to
marac and and anheiser Bush was very
proud to tell us that yeah they do
everything they brew it at at at 10% and
then they water it down to five yeah so
in anyway
as you will see that we have everything
we've done here is we are trying to
facilitate those custom Brewers I mean
it's strange seeing somebody on the
Democratic site coming out saying you
know we're certainly supporting the free
market in this type of thing but I think
that's we we
have that we have to do proponed that on
on the house
floor Market that I think this is
something because these are home Brewers
and many of them start out ABS they go
on to uh whether they come out of the
University of New Hampshire or they they
they make a good product that their
neighbors like they start a uh they
start just maybe selling it locally
getting a a nano license and then they
move up from there I think we need to
encourage that type of type of activity
in state everybody in this committee
agrees with open this up so that we can
have more of those activities occur it's
a greater Economic Opportunity that's
right I'd like it okay I think
representative Herbert had his hand up
and then you yes um it's pretty
straightforward put the mic close close
it's a a revenue question so every time
we do something different I would assume
it has an impact positive or negative on
the uh State's revenue and I'm wondering
if if you have any idea what the impact
would be uh going forward if we if we
did
this thank you for your question
representative yeah mat you
got thank you for your question
representative The Brew Pub license is
uh currently a $1,200 license we
anticipate there to be more brew pubs
um applications applied for uh
generating that Revenue type um the the
only way that uh this licensing scheme
can happen into representative um uh uh
grass's Point uh with the um nano
brewery license which was specifically
designed for the craft Brewers right
that that is a manufacturing license but
was not included
in the prohibited interest Statute in
17911 so they you can be issued that
manufacturing license and still obtain
additional restaurant licenses by
Statute one further further question you
may inquire so um so the income to the
state is limited to whatever the license
licensing ownership the licensing fees
and the the um the the production fees
on on the taxation at 30 cents a gallon
okay so there is a revenue from the
production of absolutely well that's not
the real Revenue pardon me the real
revenue is the rooms and meals tax right
that's the real reeven I mean the fees
the fees are you know theoretically it's
just paying for the department they
should not be if Avis Nichols was still
around and she was the goddess of of
fees and ways and means but is that that
uh the the fees is supposed to only
facilitate the running the operation now
what is interesting about the brew pubs
was that they went right to the 1200
which is our highest liquor license and
that and that they will also sell
distilled you know uh cocktails whereas
you could get a license as low as uh
$480 and just be a beer and wine license
so we you know there're and again the
Nano one's even cheaper so all these
license are very inexpensive that's not
where the revenue is to the state the
revenue to in the end of the day
uh the beer tax uh we have we the lowest
beer tax in around and if we pass a
bottle bill that beer tax is going to be
less Revenue so that's why we don't want
to pass that bottle Bild but but not
withstanding the the U the rooms and
meals is really been the big Revenue
generator because when all these things
we've done along the way when we allow
them to start selling the
beer then we we're getting our 8 and 1
half% tax
so it's the eight and a half it's the 8
and a half% uh is the revenue to the
state and presumably if these Pro uh
prolifer rate uh around
um that's that's the additional revenue
and no nobody knows what that might be
well it's not their job they don't you
know that's Dr whose job Dr do we are we
going to get an FN on on this or I there
the FN is nothing and we're not you know
we're this in this case we're moving the
deck chairs around on the
Titanic because theoretically you're
you're affecting somebody else who would
have gotten that that sale that's the
issue so in this Cas and this is just
the manufacturing man I don't the man
yeah the manufacturing is you know we
are the the federal tax is pretty low on
manufacturing so State the state is we
just get the 30 cents a gallon and
that's gallon 30 cents a gallon I mean
it's it's a very low tax
rate okay I mean I'm confused yes
representative
Willam thank you uh for taking my
question um are there other New
Hampshire Liquor Commission does it
operate the same as as other liquor
Commissions in other states or are you
unique or how do you differ how do we
differ uh from other states the
commission
uh thank you for your question we're
considered a a controlled alcohol State
um and there's SE 18 I was going to say
17 was it Maine Maine was in and out and
Main was 18 other controlled alcohol
States um in the country in the nation
that have similar um structures to
ours um and but they invite us to come
show them how to do it I was going to
say that but I didn't know how far to
reach there but yes you're right let me
be let me be the one that says it and
from my state my whole state of
Pennsylvania is uh as when when I I
remember as a kid when you went into the
state store the state store would have a
bot one bottle of everything on the wall
and they have all these state employees
whose job was you say okay this is what
I want and they would go in the back
back room and come out with that bottle
for you so there wasn't even self-served
back in the state liquor stores but
then and that was in New Hampshire also
yeah so but times have
changed but we we obviously take
advantage of have leveraged it well um
with our Bonded Warehouse system and
being the the distributor um and uh and
there was some question when we allow
wine into to uh um to on and off premise
the lenses that where well they on-
premise licenses would have gone through
the commission but the you know that U
that that would be a problem but
obviously it's you know wine is just I
would say is wine is where we're least
competitive against other states and
probably um because we we allowed the uh
the distribution to change on that one
so but that's a good
unique thank you very much gentlemen
thank you thank you chairman okay well
this was actually pretty good I think I
think we covered a lot of material here
and and uh question yes so I have a
parliamentary question
yes um the introduction of a bill is a
formal
process okay and we've heard four bills
this morning and I just want for the
record when were they
introduced uh they were introduced uh by
the
Departments and and and we did them each
one theoretically on
time we have a card they were introduced
they were the bills were introduced by
the department by the department thank
thank
yeah and and and um I I talked to the
house clerk he knows I do this um but
that it just when I the fact that that
these bills are my name is on them but
the the fact is that they're really
depart these are Department bills depart
the department wrote the bills part the
bills and you and most of them they well
they haven't do them here but most of
times like when the insurance or banking
it'll it'll say right on the bill by
request of the department let me just
get this straight the department writes
the bills and then the department
introduces the bills correct and that's
proper procedure U I haven't been told
so okay oh and we
do and Scott Shire is opposed to the
bill
naturally okay
um all right so we're all set and we get
to do this a little more of this this
afternoon okay all right so we're uh the
adjourn yes oh I'm sorry I have another
card I'm
sorry Ian Buckley come on
bill yeah it's on you're on just hold it
close to your fa hello Mr chairman
members of the committee my name is Ian
Buckley I'm the vice president of
Michael Timothy's dining group um and I
would just like to give a kind of a real
world example of what this bill a
problem this bill is going to help fix
so like I said um I'm with Michael
Timothy's dining group we're small
Independent Restaurant Group operate a
number of restaurants in Southern New
Hampshire uh Surf Restaurant Buckley's
great Stakes Mike's Italian Kitchen
Buckley's Bakery Cafe they're all
located in the uh southern part of the
state marac Nashua one in Portsmith and
we actually have one location in
Northern Massachusetts as well um so our
our company employs just under 500
people um and I'll tell you the just the
quick version of the the story as to how
I came to be here with this with this
bill uh about 2 years ago we purchased a
building in nashwa with the hopes of
opening a brew pub there uh it's large
building about 17,000 square ft uh we're
hoping to do about a 300 seat restaurant
as well as the the brewery side of
things a 7 barrel system so that we
could Brew our own beer uh and sell it
on premise to our guests um so we bought
the building went to Liquor Commission
uh and realized that under the you know
the current uh rules we were not allowed
to open a brew pub because we hold the
restaurant like the on- premise
restaurant licenses at our five other
locations so we sat with Liquor
Commission we were told that we would be
um able
to carry out our project by receiving a
nano breweries license as well as an on
premise restaurant license holding two
licenses um that would accomplish the
same thing uh in essence as having a
brew pub license uh I actually just this
morning on my way way here was told that
there is a bill that's being put forth
to eliminate the Nano Brewing license um
which would on the Senate side yeah yeah
which would in essence stop us dead in
our tracks because currently we're still
not allowed to apply for the Brew Pub
license which is hopefully what you
folks are going to be able to to work
with us on um we are well under
construction on that building at this
point like I said we it two years ago
we're about 3/4 of the way through our
construction we spent about $12 million
turning what was Southern New Hampshire
University Building in in Nashua into a
Restaurant and Brewery so we're in hopes
of being completed on the construction
phase within the next two to three
months and then at that point we would
be you know we were planning on applying
for uh a nano brewery and on premise
license if that is still an option for
us at that that point um but it would be
even more convenient uh for us as a
company for the inner workings of of how
it all comes together to just be able to
apply for that that Brew Pub license um
so uh that that's kind of uh where we
stand with that project I mean this this
building you know we're hoping to employ
close to 100 people at that location
alone uh you know we're thinking it's
probably going to be between a a 5 and a
half $6.5 million a year building which
you know again um the state receives
that 8 and a half% rooms and meals tax
on on that six to6 and a half million
dollars um and without help on one side
of this the other like I said we're kind
of uh dead in our tracks here after
we've found a path forward spent the
money and uh really invested the last
two years of of our
company's time energy and money into
doing something that I think is going to
be I'm hoping is going to be a really
special project in that area we
something we're very excited about um
and like I said kind of you know took
the next step as a company by by
investing in this project so that's
that's where we stand uh don't know if
there's any questions but I just wanted
to put that forth thank you okay we do
have a question representative spear
from
NASA as a very longtime customer of
Michael Timothy's and
Surf and I have eaten in your
establishments once a week but the since
that you opened up
anything that helps you serve good food
great food the way you do I'm for it
you right okay I I can attest to that he
probably has a coupon for you so right
all right right I do no I have gift re
re no I have gift certificates um I
certainly appreciate your restaurants
and your hard work um
so I'm will attend the Senate hearing
regarding the Nano breweries and they
should
not pass that bill to you know um get
rid of Nano breweries because one reason
would be you will lose a lot of money
and you make a lot of money for the
state so I'm determined to you know
Assist in that way and then this bill
should pass uh it's it's an easy one to
pass so you know you should be on your
way to opening up your restaurant when
you need to thank you I appreciate
that yeah so uh just a wrap the um I'm
I'm going to look up the intent what I
was told of the Nano bill is to try to
streamline our Byzantine system but that
obviously um remember the other thing I
said to you is that once we create
something it's very hard to get rid of
it because you have invested interests
so yes you would I I would I would be
very surprised if that Nano Bill uh gets
out of committee um because there'll be
a lot of Nano lies who would like to
keep their very special Li and for a Maj
as I understand it for a majority of
those Nano LIC
they would still have the ability to
just move into another license type that
was the idea on the manufacturing side
because we've done that we've done that
with everybody else now we with wine and
distilled we have tears but I don't have
that ability because of the separate on
premise licenses correct so eliminating
the Nano Brewery on that side would in
essence completely shut down my ability
to complete this project we we want to
make sure you're able to go forward yeah
yeah I don't know what it looks like
okay all right stay tuned to Nano after
crossover all right uh I guess we're all
set we're going to close the hearing on
1380 did you say that bill already
passed that's what he said Senate to to
get rid
yeah so yeah because he's they're
Nano
coming
for
so we're going to call the the next
public hearing to
order and this will be House Bill
11:35 relative to the definition of
specialty beer and I see the sponsor
representative
Grill uh would you come to the the
Bill thank you m chairman and thank you
to The Honorable members of the
committee um nice to be back here for a
second day in a row um so essentially
this bill um came out of a discussion
with um some friends in the bar and
restaurant industry who um described
some issues their vendors were having
with um just the confusion between the
categories of different beer products um
beer specialty beer and Specialty
beverage um so the aim of this bill um
initially was to sort of simplify that
definition of specialty beer um
currently the RSA defines a specialty
beer as a beverage that has between 6
and 12% ABV um as well as other um
differentiating features such as added
flavorings herbs spices you name it um
so the goal of this bill was to um
streamline that definition by reducing
the lower bound ABV percentage to half a
percent um while keeping the other
requirements in place um that being said
um since filing this bill I've since had
additional conversations with experts
from the beer distributors Association
um as well as more recently the Liquor
Commission as well as um members of this
committee um and it seems that um this
change that I originally requested would
um create an overlap between um some of
these existing categories which
obviously would have unintended
consequences that would go against the
purpose of simplification um so with
that in mind while I do agree that um
there are some confusing elements um
within the current statute I think that
there is a lot of um perceived gray area
among vendors and Distributors um that
should um either be cleaned up or
addressed in um on the rule side of
things um I think at this point I would
recommend in the work session um you
know we would look into putting in
either an amendment to um avoid overlap
between those categories or um if we
learn through additional research that
um this would be more of a executive um
change needed versus legislative um
recommend not moving forward with this
bill so um in in conclusion um
definitely my co-sponsors and I had
great intentions but at this time I
think it's probably not ready for prime
time and we'll need um to amend it or
otherwise you know fix it somehow so
with that mind I'll take some
questions any questions uh
representative
meckler thank you um I haven't ever seen
a beer in New Hampshire at 12% is is
there such a thing
now I um have never purchased a beer
like that myself um I can't I'm sure
there are brands that exist that do
produce beers and beverages with that
high in ABV percentage but um I don't
see too many of them in stores and I
think as far as the um the market goes
um they're probably are fewer of those
than you know what you would expect from
a PBR or Budweiser
um Miller Light type of beer so I sounds
pretty uncommon from my understanding
yeah I I I actually didn't think they
made beer at that percentage but thank
you and just clarification the bill
before us has just one change in in
language and that's to change greater
than 6% to greater than
05% and so any other language is
existing statute correct so it would
look to um reduce the um I guess lower
amount of alcohol so you could have a um
beverage that say 5.4% fall under this
category
um yes right I saw some hands over here
first representative
Bros thanks for taking my questions is
one of the problems that you see with
the bill um uh the language that it says
the beer shall possess the character and
flavor of a beer and then you have items
that aren't normally identified with a
beer like chocolate fruits nuts but that
it's not okay to have a caffeinated beer
is that one of the the problems that you
see um that wasn't my original Focus my
original Focus was more um some of the
confusion that I'd seen in the um in the
marketplace with the um amount of
alcohol required to fall into this
category versus the other categories um
so it was more meant to sort of
streamline that definition for um for
vendors and Distributors um however I
think that would be an interesting um
topic to address in future
legislation all right uh representative
U thank you Mr chairman um
representative Grill
um you use the example of
5.4% this lowers it from six all the way
down to 0. five not 05 but 0.5 and I
think that's if I read this correctly
that's the only change to existing law
that the bill as written is currently
suggesting is that right just that yes
just that change all the other
everything else all the other
requirements would say the same
caffeinated non- caffinated whatever is
already in there that's already correct
that's right representative oh followup
followup then
um who plans to sell beer with so little
alcohol content I I guess I don't quite
understand why they want to call it
Specialty Beer like any alcohol equals
specialty beer is that it um I think
these questions are highlighting some of
the um challenges that I look to address
with this bill along with uh my
co-sponsors um there are some other
categories that are very similar and
from my discussions um with the um beer
distributors Association um from my
understanding a beverage that met all
the other requirements of a specialty
beer but was under 6% would either be
classified as a beverage or just a beer
um so there is uh similar elements
between those categories um my intention
was to I guess streamline the
categorization rather than having more
of these discret categories um however
knowing that um there are currently you
know several categories of beer and
liquor in place um I want to avoid you
know as far as future amendments and
future work goes um I want to avoid you
know creating an overlap which would
just muddy the waters
further thank you representative Gibbs
you have a question uh yes thank you uh
just for clarity the language um in the
bill uh about specialty beer has to have
the character and flavor of a beer but
may have other flavoring such as fruits
chocolate and so forth that's already in
the statute that isn't new um yes that
is existing um existing language thank
you all right great any further
questions all right and uh oh you have
one more representative
post um
would you believe
that um the beer that comes out of
Belgium which is very famous um does use
12%
alcohol
um I am not a beer expert however I
um believe that there are producers of
beer who are selling beer with that high
elor content and
um possibly many of them are Belgium I
know that's a big uh big market for for
that uh for beer and related products so
if I read current law says you can have
up to
12% and uh you can get approval from the
commission for greater than 12%
so all right so thank you for your
testimony thank you and ju just one more
thing if you have an idea for an
amendment could you potentially work on
that for our subcommittee uh it sounds
like if there is no amendment that we
should vote I on the bill so yes that's
what I'm thinking and uh representative
Sven and I are um working together on on
some thoughts we have for um ways to to
clean this up so um we'll do more
research and um make more calls and get
back to you with some recommended uh
next steps great thank you thank
1135 yep one
more
call Matthew
Culver from The Liquor
Commission Matthew Culver from The
Liquor Commission please thank you last
Adrian thank you representative
committee members um I'd be happy to
discuss any questions that you might
have and provide clarification on
anything in the bill
that so I have a question uh certainly
the previous speaker mentioned that it
causes confusion in the categories could
you just elaborate on what kind of
confusion it causes certainly there's
three main definitions in RSA
1751 uh pertaining to beverages that we
typically approve there's uh
beverage um which is an alcohol
concentration of z uh six to 8%
generally speaking specialty
beverage um and Specialty Beer specialty
beer is what is in question now to
reduce that to
0.5% if that were to pass proposed
legislation you just made a specialty
beer a
beverage there would be no reason to
have the
Specialty Beer it it's overlapping um
definitions so you're changing one and
affecting the other and that is what was
trying to be explained um these are
three main categories of of definitions
that's how we approve products on on
those definitions
alone so specialty beverage can have up
to 6% alcohol is that correct specialty
beverage is 6 to 8% but specialty
Beer did you have something Adrian oh
excuse me sir uh just has something to
do with the process of manufacturing the
specialty beverage are often times some
of the products that were coming to
Market um you know the selers the the
products that um had uh different
flavorings Etc so a few years ago in the
Senate uh the bill was brought forward
to create a category of specialty
beverage which um as as the lieutenant
has said categorizes the product so when
the product comes in to the commission
for approval it's reviewed what's the
alcohol content and then it's dropped
into the category for the particular
product um type um so that it can be
categorized and then moved forward
okay you have a question representative
Walsh thank you Mr
chairman can you just Define again
because you would originally said
beverage was 6 to8 and then you just
said specialty beverage was 6 to8 so
then what's the difference between a
beverage and a specialty beverage if
it's not the alcohol content a a
beverage is 0.5% half of 1% to
6% okay a specialty beer is 6% to
12% and a specialty beverage is 6 to 8%
with further restrictions a single serve
container not to exceed 16 ounces it has
to be liquor or wine based so on and so
forth so these are all specific
definitions that live in in RSA 17
51 follow thank you so this bill is
literally to change it to
1.1% because you said it's currently 6
to 12 and it's going to go from right
it's it's going to lower the specialty
beer yeah Special definition definition
from 6% down to a half a
one% okay okay got you thank you
representative Sol
thank you so maybe you could just help
like educate me as a co-sponsor who was
just trying to make things a little bit
simpler to and the rest of the committee
what is the logic behind all these
different Cate categories like there
there's got to be a reason why we've
created
them but the creation of them definitely
at some levels created confusion the
fact that people here don't understand
why we have the different different
categories maybe you can help us
understand that a little
bit it's thank you representative I I
will certainly try to do that I I'm
happy to maybe meet with you separately
maybe now it's not the best venue but
well very simply very simply put let
let's take the specialty beverage which
is the last um type of beverage that we
saw in the market it's the rtds right
the ready to drink Cocktails so as the
industry changes so do the requirements
for these definitions they're a little
bit different than what the existing
definitions already are
so new definitions are made in order for
um these products to be approved and and
and brought into the state for for a
retail sale um so I think that's the
best explanation that I can give on that
um you know as as the industry changes
as these products change um the statutes
are changing the definitions are
changing follow up follow so I guess my
my knee-jerk reaction or gut instinct
tells me that there's some I mean is the
OB
objective at some level is to cor
collect revenue and you have to figure
out where to bucket that Revenue because
I know beer is treated differently than
say a spirit right so would it make
sense or can you see a world where we
would have just sort of one category
based on alcohol volume and and that's
and I understand that beer is treated
differently now it's it's it's so like
but like I wonder if there maybe could
be two categories something that isn't
considered a spirit and then we could
just have like one one or two categories
that are just based on alcohol volume
because it seems to me like yeah there's
going to be all sorts of innovation that
comes across from the market whether
it's premixed seltzers or premixed uh
you know Margaritas or whatever but also
different types of beers that come up
that have like in this thing there's
like flavors of coffee and all those
sorts it just seems like there's an
infinite potential number of categories
we could have and and that's I think is
what we were trying to get at and we
didn't realize the can worms were
opening but uh I don't know if you have
any insight or or perhaps you and I
could meet sometime to discuss this
because this is something I do care
about and I realize that this isn't
really ready for what we're trying to do
but certainly and and thank you for that
representative I I think um you you were
right in in saying that it it does open
up a can of worms U um title 13 is very
much so interwoven in in changing one
aspect of any statute or definition
directly affects several others um but
if you would like to meet offline I I
would certainly um entertain in in and
and offer my feedback on on uh
simplifying this that certainly been our
intentions as well in the in the last um
several years
cool all right representative
Gibbs thanks than you Mr chair um I'm
afraid I'm more confused now than I was
um before you started um uh you
mentioned three categories um the first
one having uh alcohol half a per to 6%
the second one 6% to 8% and the third
one 6% to 12% did I have that right
that's correct um but there are a lot of
alcoholic beverag es uh that we would
consider liquor or spirits that have
alcohol percentages substantially higher
than 12% so are these categories um only
beer type Beverages and are those liquor
or or Spirit beverages in a totally
different set of
categories thank you for your question
representative um my name is Aiden Moore
I'm the legal coordinator for the State
Liquor Commission um and I first want to
commend Matt for doing an excellent job
of explaining a lot of the legislation
that's come before today he's really
done a fabulous job um alcohol is gets
into the marketplace based upon how it
is categorized so some of the
definitions that are part of this you
can well imagine um many many years
ago what what do you what is a beer well
it's a it's beer it's not you know it's
how it's manufactured what's the
ingredients and as the marketplace
started to started to change some of the
formulations have changed and you've
seen in this definition for example the
reference to herbs and fruits and nuts
and things like that which usually that
was not many years ago how beer was made
it was made with hops and it's kind of a
traditional recipe of sorts so depending
upon how the product is classified as as
the lieutenant has stated product comes
into the commission they want it
approved for for sale in the state and
as a part of that there's a some type of
a lab analysis that comes in and says
this is what the alcohol content is
based upon that it is dropped into the
category is it a beverage or a beer of
one half of 1% to
six is it still a beer but the alcoholic
content is
higher and as a result it becomes uh the
request for a specialty beer
and then you have this other category
which was established a few years ago
which was a specialty beverage and the
beverage has to do with the
manufacturing
ingredients and and that has a lot to
drive so for example if you go to the
next level Beyond just beverage you can
look at wine you can look at table wine
table wine goes up to
15.5% then you have fortified wine but a
lot of this has to do with where the
product moves into the marketplace so Mr
sh who uh members are wholesalers would
distribute beer or anything under 6%
alcohol by volume a specialty beer
because of what it is they would also
distribute
that specialty
beverages now has the ability to be
distributed by the wholesalers but also
sold by The Liquor Commission
and the Liquor Commission of course is
the wholesaler of wine in the state to
other retailers and the exclusive agent
for
Spirits so uh further question further
question thank you uh but what what is
the category for wine that is 15%
alcohol and what is the category for
spirits that are say 20%
alcohol 15% Al alcohol wine would be a
table wine that's that's how it would be
categoried in the statute the statute
speaks to a definition in
1751 uh defines uh table wines the
product that is
20% would be be by virtue of its alcohol
content would become something that the
commission would distribute it would be
classified as wine or a spirit and then
moved into into the marketplace through
the commission's distribution
Network thank
questions just just one question about
any beers that are over 12% are they
distributed strictly by The Liquor
Commission instead of through
Distributors because I know there are
some beers that are over 12% you can't
Hampshire
uh representative thank you I'm not
aware that the commission is selling
some of those products but if there was
a product that was to come into the
marketplace and have the characteristics
of a beverage beer in the way it's
produced um and its content was over 12%
and not able to be identified as a
specialty beer then the distribution
would come through the Liquor Commission
Sam Adams has one that's 28%
then then that would be sold in the
stores all right thank you
representative grassy and uh I
appreciate the spirit of this bill which
is to simplify potentially simplify the
statutes because they're easier to
enforce and for the public to understand
so so maybe there's something we can uh
move forward on find out all right thank
you for your testimony anyone else would
like to testify on this legislation
1:45
Hillsboro 39 which is Manchester's WS
689 or as I like to call the fight in
South End um I'm here to introduce uh
hb32 3 sorry
1321 um which pertains to the stickers
we we currently require be put onto kegs
so party on um going to try to get these
stickers off um basically what happens
is when you buy a um a keg over seven
gallons uh in order to sell those the
seller has to go to a liquor store the
actual Brewer has to go to a liquor
store uh get the stickers the tags if
you will from The Liquor Commission then
they have to go and they have to put the
customers personal identifying
information on that tag um place it onto
the keg and then log it into the um
liquor commissions system keep
everything in triplicate copy all in the
all of for the purpose of preventing the
sale and possession of alcohol to miners
so in the 20 years that this system has
been in placed there has been a grand
total of zero times uh that they have
actually stopped St a minor from from
doing from doing this um The Liquor
Commission here I believe is they will
testify that it's time to kind of just
move on and this is one of those easy
things that we can do um they can damage
the kegs in the long term they're hard
to come off um the term that uh is given
by my constituents is it's like super
glue trying to get it off so they have
to like power wash it it's wild um but
this is not um my area of expertise uh
so I won't be taking questions I'm going
to do what I hate when people do an I'm
chair and I'm going to totally not
answer your questions but there are
plenty of people behind me um that will
be happy to answer your questions so
thank you guys so
much any questions that I won't be
taking that I won't be taking thank you
representative oh I'm sorry I should say
I have an amendment that actually tries
I I apologize I do have an amendment in
front of you guys uh H uh 2024 0123 H
I'm lucky to get that number um that
actually kind of fixes what we were
trying to do originally but uh didn't
quite make it out of OLS in time so
while I can't speak to the amendment
because that would be inappropriate I do
hope the committee will uh look at the
amendment because that's what we were
trying to do um and maybe save you some
time if you decide this is uh worth your
efference so thanks guys so much thank
you representative I'm sure the
subcommittee okay anyone else want to
speak
know thanks
Aiden okay uh
Aiden Moore and Matthew cber from the
Liquor
you thank you Mr chairman uh again my
name is Aiden Moore legal coordinator
for the Liquor Commission um we just
wanted to speak briefly to a little bit
of the uh history of The Keg label
process in case you were interested
before you make a decision to repeal it
we can tell you why it was put in place
um I happen to be uh the chief of
enforcement when I wrote this bill so um
I guess I'm it's good that I'm here when
it might be repealed very useful very
helps
um as you know underage drinking and
Public Safety are an extremely important
part of the commission's function
especially with the division uh of
enforcement the intent was looking at
some of the best practices that existed
around the country back when the bill
was brought back in the 9s that keg
registration was a
promising enforcement process and
deterrent for those people who would go
and buy keg beer and provide it to
miners so you may may or not may or may
not have had in your community a case
where there's a house party and and the
police come and there are a number of
young people there and it may have been
that the only thing that was Remnant
left there was the keg and the question
always was who owns The Keg where did
The Keg come from who bought it because
if you buy alcohol for a minor that's a
crime and as a result law enforcement
needed to be able to have tools to
investigate and Trace back the process
to where this product came from um we
worked with the industry to try to I'm
not sure when you know I I hear the
story about glue because the glue was a
big issue when we passed this law and uh
we went to the industry itself and said
you know you put you're the beverage
manufacturers you put tags on on your
kegs right you you scrub them off when
they come in they go yeah what do you
put that on with well with glue well
we'll use the same glue you use because
that way we'll all come off everything
will come off same time so that's been
the practice is to use the same glue
that the industry uses to uh adhere the
tags and to remove the tags um I think
Lieutenant culber can speak to the cost
of the program and um what it may do if
this is repealed to remove some of the
responsibilities from the commission and
save a little time um but we still are
obviously concerned to make sure that
law enforcement has the ability to have
all the tools necessary to try to
enforce this very important function of
Public Safety and trying to keep miners
from consuming alcohol and the
unfortunate tragedies that often occur
after that would you like to say
anything
M thank you committee members um and
certainly uh Mr Moore is absolutely
correct the division of enforcement
takes underage drinking very seriously
um and and wouldn't be recommending
anything that would would jeopardize
that that uh aspect of the laws um to
provide some clarity uh on uh the
testimony that was provided by the bill
sponsor
um it is true that um we've had very
little reports of any incidents being
solved by these keg tags um a few if any
um in the time that I've been with the
Liquor Commission or as a law
enforcement officer
um one of the first things that
typically is done when a cake is
purchased is what you put it in a barrel
of ice correct and The Keg tag is
usually not very well preserved after
spending hours in a bucket of ice um
they are very expensive um The Keg tags
our
last our last order of the keg tags is
somewhere around $88,700 um for a th000
cases um of of keg tags so um I'd be
happy to answer any questions that you
have uh we do have ad administrative
rule in existence on on this it's uh uh
liquor rule
506 um
06 uh and that's pursuant to the uh
current statute that authorizes the
administrative rule to be
there thank
you
representative so what what is your
position like do you think that this is
something that we should try to keep or
is this something that you're like yeah
let's let's move on it wasn't clear from
what you just I appreciate that
representative um I believe the
commission as a whole will will remain
neutral on this bill um however I I do
believe that um the intent of this bill
uh
the practices that we've seen with the
intended um the intent of this
protecting has moved beyond that um uh
in that it's not effective right now
basically right it's not effective
anymore thank you
thanks than you representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair I'm just trying
to figure out the difference between the
original bill and the amendment and the
only things that I can see are the
amendment adds the words uh the
differences are in the definition of K
and the amendment has the words refill
um which makes perfect sense no no
question about that um and then changes
uh just at the end um uh the end of the
definition s gallons to 64 fluid ounces
which is half a
gallon and is that intentional change
from seven gallons to half a
gallon thank you representative I I
don't have a copy of the current
amendment I believe that was just
uh well the the sponsor didn't want to
o okay looking at line nine of the
amendment
than
um I believe representative I I think
the this bill sponsor May best be able
to answer this um the way I see this is
that the the uh change in this is
refillable and changing s gallons to 64
fluid ounces and I I don't know why that
was done if well is the sponsor sorry is
the sponsor willing to take the
question all right um Let me let me get
my point in here I think technically the
bill as introduced is what we can talk
about today the amendment will be
representative any more
questions uh thank you gentlemen I
appreciate it uh I think Kristen
there up
Car hi so I'm Kristen NBS I'm co-founder
and owner of Tuckerman Brewing Company
and I'm also president of the New
Hampshire Brewers Association and I can
speak to the scrap metal piece of this
uh the amendment as well when uh when we
proposed the bill to get rid of the RSA
involving the keg registration tags it
was linked to the scrap metal RSA and
when we looked at that um it had the
definition of a keg as over seven
gallons uh but a lot of Us sell five
gallon kegs too so seeing as it was
already being looked at we asked it it
be changed to a smaller
volume
thank you okay uh but yes but my name is
Carson nevs and I'm here in support of
this bill um we've been selling kegs for
many years at our Brewery since we
opened in '98 and we've had to fill out
a lot of these keg tags over the years
um and it seems like whenever anybody
wants to purchase a keg it's at our
busiest times on a Saturday afternoon
and it takes a fair amount of time uh
for the customer to fill out the
information um and then also another
part of the problem for us is that we
have to get the keg books at the liquor
store and when we go to the liquor store
um they don't do a lot of The Keg
registration tags for for retailers like
us so there's a lot of confusion as to
how to issue them to us and it's kind of
a lengthy process of checking them out
and registering the books uh so it takes
some time and in fact our manager was at
the liquor store in Conway yesterday and
got turned away after spending about a
half hour there as people tried to
figure out how to issue the The Keg Tag
books to us so that takes a fair amount
of time and also uh The Liquor
Commission uh comes to the brewery
multiple times a year to do audits of
our records and when they do that they
have to go through the registration
books uh Page by Page make sure that
they were filled out correctly so that
takes a lot of extra time for both us
and the Auditors to go through uh and
then as as people have mentioned before
about the glue uh you know the Liquor
Commission should be applauded for this
for finding the supplier on these things
because they the glue on them is super
strength and you cannot get it off um so
we spend like many many hours trying to
soak them and scrub them and scrape them
off of the Kegs and uh it's really hard
to get them off and it has a lot of the
customers personal information on there
so it seems like a a security kind of
breach to the people's personal
information to have them on
there uh but yeah I'm happy to answer
any questions as
well thank you
representative thank you very much um do
you did you submit your testimony um to
the committee uh no I did not would you
be able to do that sure thank
questions raise your hand well I just
tapped you okay represent representative
Heber my my question is uh I'm pretty
naive about this but we went from seven
gallons to a half a gallon
oh four gallons four gallons what was
the size uh 64 ounces I think 163 yeah
four gallons half a gallon four gallons
so so you've got a smaller
ceg uh and and if and if this U
legislation was were to be passed you
wouldn't have uh I'm just
curious I'm just need to know that
uh there do you need to have uh some
sort of record of this I mean so the
change the change of the volume was was
related to this um scrap metal RSA which
asks like a scrap metal uh company if
they find a brewery's keg not to just
scrap it for the metal value because the
kegs are very expensive for the
breweries uh they're $150 for a
full-size keg and even a five gallon keg
costs over $100 so uh there was an RSA
that was added uh many years ago to try
to get the scrap metal suppliers to
contact the breweries if they got any in
um so unfortunately in order to get rid
of The Keg registration tags it's tied
legislatively to the scrap metal RSA so
that's why this amendment is coming up
if if the amendment passes and all this
you're going to have more sales of kegs
probably because they're smaller um no
we already sell the K the smaller kegs
now in fact the majority of the kegs
that we sell are uh 5.17 gallons but for
some reason the keg reg registration
tags are only required for the fulls
size keg which is uh 15.5 gallons so
that's you know that's another thing
with the keg registration tags that
doesn't makes sense is that the volume
that people actually want which is a
smaller size keg they don't even require
a tag for so and and I should have
mentioned earlier you know the first
thing that we do when we sell beer of
any package size is is ID somebody and
make sure they're of age so The Keg
registration tags are are sort of
redundant and also just a lot of time
and energy for everybody so um further
question is is uh so you have a system
of
recording how many of these kegs you
sold and to
whom so right now uh through the the for
The Keg registration tags we have to
record a person's name and address no
forget the tag I'm just I'm just
wondering if you have but in general if
we didn't have the tags we wouldn't
necessarily have a record of who we sold
beer to other than the information on
the POS system if they paid with a
credit card we would have that
information but not with cash but 95% of
our customers pay with credit cards now
so we do have some record there but but
you check how old they are I mean you
know yeah yep okay absolutely all right
thank
you uh any question uh representative
Gibb
thank you Mr chair just to be sure we're
all on the same page and everything
makes
sense 64 fluid ounces is half a
gallon was that intentional half a
gallon uh yeah the intent was just to to
size that that's not an actual I mean
that's not really a keg size that
anybody uses but I think the the
intention was just to reduce it to
something really small just so that we
would be contacted if any refillable
container showed up at a scrapyard in
the state thank
you I I have a question so for the
fullsize kegs you do have to have the
records for the mini kegs you don't
that's correct so if I walked in instead
of getting one of these jamong us guys I
I picked up four small kegs which was
more than this as long as I show 21 I
can take them away yep that's correct
yeah you
don't well I'm inviting you
too and also uh second second
question can you not get these tags that
for the big guys in advance from the
Conway state store instead of having to
go down oh I need two tags today I need
need three tags to can't you get a a
stack of like 20 uh they don't usually
have 20 on hand but we do usually go and
try to get at least um at least four or
five booklets at a time so we don't have
to run to the the liquor store every
single time we sell a keg uh but we have
to fill out the tag and the information
I also brought one with me if you guys
want to see it so this is a state
Logistics problem that they don't have a
quantity of these in our high Recreation
areas where you will typically find
spirits well yeah unfortunately they
just I don't think they really serve a
purpose because we're carding everybody
for any package size anyway and the
smaller kegs like you said you can buy
three what we call a log uh because it's
tall and narrow um so you can buy three
logs it's the same volume as one half
barrel keg it's easier to move around
you can get a variety of different beers
so most people go that route um um a lot
of the consumers that purchase kegs from
us are regulars that have kegerators in
their house and a lot of them like to
have a variety of beers so many of them
purchase the smaller kegs and there
there is not the requirement for the
registration tag uh but but when we do
have somebody that wants one then we
have to go through those extra efforts
and it just is pretty timec
consuming okay thank you very much any
more
questions thank you very much thank you
and
we're journ
1334 John is that oh that's much better
people
seconds this
one
yeah
oh okay yeah that makes it easier
laptop all
right call the uh the hearing for House
Bill 1334 to order and the title is
relative to the sale of be beer and in
refillable containers and we have the
prime sponsor here representative turkot
thank you Mr chairman good afternoon
members of Commerce uh my name is
representative Len turkot I represent
the towns of barington and straford in
straford County District 4 uh fourth
term rep and currently serve as chairman
of the house and uh Municipal uh house
Municipal and County government
committee I am here today as a prime
sponsor on HB 1330 four which is
relative to the sale of beer and
refillable
containers um I'm going to really it's a
very quick easy short bill so I'm going
to read uh the one new paragraph and it
says where a liy is authorized the
retail sale of beer in a refillable
container such lensey at his discretion
may fill such refillable container with
his product regardless of The Branding
on the refillable container I'll note
that um one important word in here is
the sale of beer this is only uh
regarding beer it's not any beverages
when I first brought the my wording to
the OS they they made it similar to a
previous bill that I'm going to talk
about which was any beverage this is
specifically for
beer so the reason for this today is
really to clarify um as I said back in
2001 for anybody who was on this
committee a representative PR Prime
sponsor had introduced HB
403 during that testimony which I went
back and
reviewed uh an attorney from The Liquor
Commission uh when he
testified said that bill was not needed
because it was already permitted
although it didn't specifically say
within the RSA that was permitted he
said there's nothing that prevented a um
a brewer from actually refilling a
growler
um with his beer even though it said
something different on it and for those
of you who do not know what a growler is
I'm not allowed to show props here but
after the no there are no Growlers on
there but I do have a couple from my
vast colle ction with me that I'd be
happy to show you after the after the
hearing um so anyway as I was saying
back on that bill um the liquor
commissioner uh the attorney from the
liquor commissioner said that there was
no prohi uh prohibition against it so
representative Prout at the end of the
hearing said well I guess we don't
really need to do this and they dropped
it well the problem with that was
um we had contradictions going forward
contradictions and uh lacks of
clarification I'm going to give you two
examples of that and then you will hear
actually from one U micr Brewer um he'll
be testifying here shortly to the second
one I'll I'll mention briefly the first
one is my local Brewer as an example and
I've asked others as I've traveled
around they just simply don't think
they're allowed to do it you know I
brought in uh a growler one time to my
local Brewer top water brewing in
barington I said hey um can I do you
have any Growlers I'd like to buy one no
we're out of them I said can you fill
one of my my Growlers oh no we can't do
that I said there's nothing prevents
that he goes yeah I know we'd like to
but there's nothing that says we can
okay the second issue was although we
had on tape from HB
403 the attorney from The Liquor
Commission saying there is no
prohibition and you'll hear from our
Brewer who's going to testify here
shortly that in fact the liquor
inspector told him no you can't do that
so we're having
conflicting
um counsel from uh different individuals
within the Liquor Commission so this
bill here is
simply meant to clarify and delineate
once and for all there's no proh uh
it now what I passed out in front of you
is as I Was preparing this bill in my
travels I uh my past time favorite
pasttime is visiting micro
breweries
and what you have in front of you is
what I would
consider
misbranding I'm not opposed to it
because I don't think it really matters
but it's a great example of what I would
consider Miss branding and if you look
in the first picture
that was a beer I got at Peppers Landing
in Rochester and I ordered a stoneface
brewing IPA which is made down in
Portsmouth New Hampshire so the Stone
Face came in a pint glass that didn't
say stoneface Brewing on it again
happens all the time not opposed to it
doesn't matter to me the second one
you'll see is a Shipyard Brewing glass
from Portland Maine
and they make okay beers to be honest
but what I have in there is a
litherman's brewing misguided Angel IPA
litherman's is down in the south side of
conquer here so we have a litherman's
brewing IPA being served in a shipyard
glass at tandies across the street again
who cares
right the last one I have it's my
favorite I have an escape Brewing
Company this was actually taken down I
took this picture in Florida uh I have
what they call an other coast west other
West Coast IPA served in of all things a
Bud Light Glass and again doesn't matter
to me I don't care what I'm drinking out
of just like I don't care when I take
one of my Growlers and go to top water
Brewing if it says um Alcatraz Brewing
on it I don't care what it says on the
bottle what I care is what comes out of
it and I would contend that in fact
um a brewer using a growler at a micr
um frame on it name on
it is you're getting a much better idea
of what what's actually going in because
for anybody who who who's not familiar
with it you take your Growler you go up
to the micr he fills it in front of you
you see what's going in normally they'll
throw a tag on it telling you what it is
and you go home when you order a a beer
in a
restaurant you're s most of the time
you're not even close to where you're
sitting uh where they pour the beer so
in actuality when I order stoneface IPA
um at Pepper's Landing I don't know if
I'm really get in a stone face IPA
whereas with a growler in fact that's
for um the last point
uh before I close up here was kind of
along the lines what I was just saying
there and that is the purchaser when you
use a growler the purchaser knows what
he's getting because he can see it and
the seller knows what he's putting in
there so as I said this is meant to
clarify um what the attorney for House
Bill 403 in 2021 said that there is no
prohibition against it so we're just
putting that into the RSA so there is no
um uh interpretation issues for the
Brewers out
there
um we think it makes sense it's very
simple and again um when we're done this
hearing anybody who doesn't know what a
growler is I'd be happy to show you what
it is so I'll take any questions anybody
point representative post I all your
head first would you ask your question
thank you Mr chairman um so here it says
may fill such a refillable container
that gives them the discretion to not um
pour you into a separate container
because perhaps they want to sell it to
you is that a situation that's exactly
right it the it's a key line at their
soul his sole discretion so if I take my
alcatra Brewing Growler into my top
water brewing and I go hey um give me
one of your ipas and I show him the
alcatra he goes no I don't want to fill
that this bill says that's his option
there's nothing that forces him to do it
but allows him to it and I can guarant
almost guarantee with
100% uh
certainty that the micr Brewer is going
to be more than happy to fill whatever
Growler you bring in with his
product representative
spear thank you I I don't know anything
about this I've never drunk beer so I
don't know anything about it but would
it ever be a case where Bud Light or
aneisa bush would not want you to put
someone else's beer in a glass that they
sold assuming that it was going to be
for uh a Bud Light I
guess I can't answer that question
because I don't know what anheiser Bush
thinks about doing with their glasses
you know in restaurants and bars I would
imagine they probably don't care either
because they're getting the advertising
on their glass I know for fact that I I
travel a country in the world I've got
glasses and uh all from all over the
place and
uh these are just a small sample of what
I've seen you know I've had ipas of one
company in an IPA glass of another
company I mean it just it really who
cares just just it's just an advertising
thing for them yeah I I would say okay I
don't know but I would say yeah so just
to clarification this spill isn't about
glasses it's about Growlers refillable
containers Growlers again which I will
be glad to hold up when I'm not sitting
at this so the the glasses were was just
an example of the different beers being
put and we have to take your word for it
that the beer in the glass is actually
what you you would have to take my word
for that but I I can guarantee you there
would be in any of those pictures there
would be nothing other than an IPA in
those glasses that I can guarantee you I
do understand that but Growlers also
have advertising on them so so do does
bud lighter one and AER Bush do they
have grow Growlers with uh that's a good
question I don't I've never seen one
only because they they're sort of more
of the mass producers you know cans and
bottles is where they put out their
their stuff I don't I've never seen a
growler uh somebody who's going to
testify might be able to clarify that
but I've never seen one it's usually the
the small micro breweries that have the
The Growlers any followup good all right
any other questions representative meu
thanks thanks for bringing this up um
just a quick question do we do we have a
definition of a refillable container I
was just trying to find it in statute
and and the part B of that is does it is
it supposed to have a a method of
closure cap cork lid some kind I this
the bill that
I'm put forth is basically for Growlers
is there a cap yes and again once I
leave here I will be gladly holding up
examples of Growlers and you will see
that they have caps on them um there are
other containers micr breweries use but
they're um like a the other one is
called a crowler and that is a smaller
unit but it's actually uh a unit that
they can write at their own place
refillable this a growler is a an
example of a refillable container I'm
sure they have smaller variations but in
general it's definitely capped yes
follow thanks my followup is I I guess
as I read it as written without a
specific definition that says a method
of
closure then all of these glasses do
apply the glasses that the Distributors
provide for free to the lienes so that
they'll use them for advertising no I
don't think so just because of the uh I
think I have it here the section that
it's talking about um I printed out
everything and left it on my wife's
printer um I don't I do not believe
that's the case it could be interpreted
that way maybe but I'd have to get back
into the RSA again I I left that on my
wife's
printer representative
post would you believe that Budweiser
has a beer garden Growler in several
sizes would I
believe possibly I I do know that uh the
big beer companies have uh bought up a
lot of uh not micro micr breweries but
bigger micr breweries I've been to
several down
Virginia um so maybe indirectly but I
don't
know and uh just to follow up on
representative post question uh who who
owns The Growler once it's in someone's
Possession It The Growler is um normally
provided initially from the micro Brewer
the seller um the per the person who
buys the beer in The Growler purchases
The Growler and then The Growler belongs
to that individual from then on that's
them any other
questions all right seeing none thank
you for your testimony thank
you and uh next up we have Rob Collins
minutes you want to just pass out the
you can just hand it to representative
Grass
either and and you're you supporting
you're supporting the
correct
thank you for the opportunity to provide
testimony and support of HB 1334 my name
is Rob Collins I live at 260 Stone Road
in Brookfield my wife Katherine and I
own and
operate
close thank you is that better
okay uh my wife Katherine and I own and
operate Frost heave Brewery in
Brookfield we have held a New Hampshire
Liquor Commission nano brewery license
since since November 2021
Frost heave is a small Brewery our
entire facility is 850 squ ft which
houses our Tasting Room restroom storage
and beer production we produce
approximately 50 barrels of beer in
2023 all beer that we produce is poured
in The Tasting Room we do not package
any of our beers in cans or
bottles refillable containers also known
as Growers are important to our business
model during December 2023 just last
month onethird of the beer we sold was
delivered in Growlers Growlers provide a
lowcost option for our customers to take
home our take our beer home with them to
consume at times when we are not
open Growlers are much lower cost than
cans which require a can lid label labor
to fill seal and label the can and
storage for both empty and filled cans
canning literally does not fit in our
building nor our business
model many of our customers already have
several branded growlers from other
local breweries and they would like us
to fill them with frost heave beer I was
explicitly told by the New Hampshire
Liquor Commission that we are not
permitted to do so James barbouti on
March 4th 2022 in an email said quote it
is misbranding by putting your beer into
someone else's Growler end quote and he
referenced uh New Hampshire RSA 175
colon 2 adulteration and or
misbranding I will note that we are
required to fix an approved label with
our Brewery name to any unbranded growl
that we fill and presumably would
likewise likewise be required to do so
for any other branded Growler if we were
allowed to me the concern that a
consumer is likely to be confused about
what beer is in their Growler seems
overblown at best the consumer owns The
Growler they wash The Growler they
brought it to Frosty Brewery to be
filled they watched me fill it I
attached a label that says the beer is
from froste Brewery and they take The
Growler home I can't imagine that there
that there is any cause for confusion
this definitely does not seem like an
example of
misbranding in any restaurant in New
Hampshire licensed by the same Liquor
Commission you can order a pint of Bud
and wind up with it delivered in a
Miller branded glass nobody's confused
about what beer is in the glass there's
be the federal regulator specifically
the ttb
have a couple dozen pages of regulations
around every aspect of what must be or
may be on a beer label along with an
exhaustive process of for label
approvals how many pages of regulations
does the ttb have on
Growlers zero they treat it as if it was
a big serving glass and they have no
regulations about that at all they're
extremely concerned about consumer
customer confusion on can or bottle
labels but have no concerns about it
about a container that is filled on
demand for the
consumer allowing breweries to fill the
customer's Growler regardless of
branding is good for the breweries good
for the customers and good for our state
by removing barriers to customers
purchasing our beer you will help
increase beer sales and increase the
state's collection of the associated
excise tax of 30 cents a gallon in
addition enabling additional reuse of of
existing Growlers is good for the
environment and saves the customer from
having to purchase and store yet another
growler I urge you to support this
Common Sense measure it is a small but
meaningful way to support New
Hampshire's thriving craft beer economy
thank you for your consideration I'd be
happy to answer any questions you might
have thank you Mr Collins for your
committee I have one for you if you
don't mind um what uh when a customer
hands you a growler that they brought in
what kind of check do you do on that
container to make sure it doesn't have
other liquid in it or it's dirty or so I
I open I remove the lid usually comes in
with a lid screw it on I unscrew the lid
I will look in it if there's any liquid
in there which is there often is because
they probably just washed it I'll I'll
pour out any excess liquid if it looks
dirty I'm going to call it I'm going to
call it to their attention and you
know
usually it happens occasionally that
somebody will bring in a dirty growler
and I call it to their attention and we
generally don't fill it because it's you
know who wants who wants boldy beer
right that would be but it's there it's
their and and it would be my discretion
I mean I'm I'm not going to pour my beer
into a moldy container right right it's
just why would I do that to my beer
right um if it's if it's quiet I'll wash
it if it's busy I
won't great thanks for answering any
other questions hard see none thank you
for your testimony thank you and uh your
your your printed copy will go in the
file for this Bill thank
you all right and uh we'll call Chief
armaganian
up uh Matt Culver and Aiden Moore all G
to Triple team
it oh he left okay and uh from the New
Hampshire Liquor
Commission thank you Mr chairman
honorable committee members again for
the record uh Mark armaganian chief of
enforcement for the liquor Comm Mission
with me today as you have heard several
times uh Lieutenant Matt Culver uh who's
our commander of
administration auditing direct shipping
licensing uh and where's about six other
heads too that will add to it at some
point um I I think from informal
conversations that we have had here uh
conversations that I have had uh with
the representative uh I I won't disagree
with anything there uh other than um um
there was probably some misinformation
that was put out uh back in the day uh
Mr bar beauty isn't with us um for a
couple years now uh Matt can speak more
toward the auditing side I think over
covid HHS had um a standard they put out
about not refilling uh bottles but what
one thing we don't want to see is this
as as Mr chairman as you and I have
spoken about is this interrupting the
spirit side of the house um so the
placement of where this is would would
be critical and and we can talk about
where where this does sit uh in the
statute the word Growler isn't defined
uh refillable containers is uh so as you
all know we're we're in a uh committee
that everything is defined and if it
isn't it didn't it doesn't exist so
um so that would be our only standing in
this is is how this is placed in the
statute um and I'll leave the rest for
Matt to talk
about thank you
Chief chairman and committee members uh
this is an amendment to
17940 paragraph it is inserting a new
paragraph paragraph three and Par the
existing 17940 paragraph 2 States no
licensees shall refill any bot of
Legally purch purchased beverage or
liquor and then paragraph three would be
this change so our recommendation would
to be in paragraph three to say
notwithstanding paragraph two so you're
not you're providing that delineation
and not a contradiction to two
paragraphs paragraph two obviously is
for uh the refilling of liquor bottles
using uh the um leader bottles to the
750 milliliter at the Wells and
restaurants um the refilling of those
Brands other than that I appreciate the
presentation by the co-sponsor and in
our lense e
um so I hope this is good for them great
thank you um I'm just trying to follow
along with what your previous statement
was so I think sometimes an
unscrupulous bar owner could refill a
container um you know I the end of the
night they could refill it with uh that
particular brand or some other brand is
that what the existing statutes partly
why it's uh for liquor purposes yeah for
liquor purposes yes that's that's
exactly and and that's a common practice
um amongst lenses is something that we
do um um watch out for and try to
educate our lenses on on that that
that's not
allowable um and like the testimony that
was provided earlier there's also um the
substitution of Brands right right so
you are filling a um top shelf bottle
with exactly bottom shelf B light
yeah all right great y any questions
from the
committee represent M thank you Mr
chairman chief do either of you guys
know what that definition of refillable
container is I still couldn't find it I
was just browsing through
179 is that a cap I I believe it's
actually mentioned as suitable container
um uh and I the statute is escaping me I
couldn't find it in 179 we can research
that for you so you're the the
security uh cap on top or the the
closure cap you're you're speaking of
Representative or uh fur further
question if you don't mind further
question yeah I'm just wondering if we
need to make it include that so people
don't want to just bring in their own
glasses which maybe we don't object to
that it's fine with me I I sure owners
thank you representative I believe it it
might be worth um discussing the
possibility of creating a definition for
a growler we can do SUB committee right
you said it was already there so I just
wanted to read
it all right I I just did a quick search
on refillable container in RSA I don't I
got zeros also maybe yeah it's suitable
container I suitable suitable should be
there
somewhere and if I can't find it now
later all right
uh that had nine hits so in in different
beverage licenses there's a suitable
container definition
yeah all right any other
questions and so just to recap it sounds
like it's a workable bill it may need an
Amendment or two uh one Amendment with
one or two changes um absolutely and it
it'll it'll fit in that statute but it
doesn't need to contradict it correct
right all right excellent any anyone
else would like to testify on this
bill and if not seeing none we'll close
the hearing on House Bill
1334 we're done we're back here Tuesday
at 10: a.m. Tuesday we're actually in
room
306 Tuesday on Tuesdays yeah we're down
the
hall